Sure. I spent the beginning of my career
working on mobile and communications technologies
both in the government and venture capital
investing in emerging communications technology.
And transition from there to healthcare have an M.D.
and a PhD in Pharmacology from Emory and did my clinical training in OB GYN.
And decided to leave clinical medicine and focus again on innovation.
But now and the health care sector
and did some work in venture capital before starting RIMIDI.
I was working with a venture capital group that was talking to
Fortune 500 companies about what drives their health care cost.
And some of the expected usual suspects,
they're Cancer, Pre-term birth.
But I was really surprised that chronic diseases like Diabetes were top
five health care cost for all of these corporations.
And you know, I had the C level suite from companies like Delta
talking to me about Diabetes which is a clinician didn't make any sense to me.
You know we know how to manage those diseases.
How can we do such a poor job.
And when I looked into it really decided it was an execution problem.
We weren't using data effectively to
manage the disease in the way that we should be able to.
So RIMIDI's product is a software platform that
focuses on the whole spectrum of what's needed in diabetes management.
From patient self-management to
population management to clinical analytics for providers.
So we share data across that spectrum patient
generated health data that comes from sensors and devices
and wearables as well as
the electronic medical record data that we pull from the EMR systems.
And then we perform the analytics on that data to give the right insights and
actions to those end users.
Sure, so a couple of problems we're addressing there one is there are
these general population health tools that have been implemented to really help define
populations in cohorts of patients within
a system and to help that system understand where their pain points are.
But defining population health doesn't solve the problem.
Someone put it to me last week.
It doesn't change the clinical workflow to know what the problem is in your population.
So remedies really digging into that.
So our predictive analytics both help the health system know
how to prioritize and triage the patients with a particular health condition.
So they know where to spend their time.
But then at the individual patient level,
we let them see the anticipated impact of treatment decisions.
So, were short circuiting this trial and error process of handing a patient
a new prescription waiting six months for them to come back and
see what happened and then iterating on that decision again.
It were allowing all of that iteration on screen in front of
the clinician so they can make
a much more targeted decision about patient treatments right there.
Exactly. Yeah, so on screen you can interact with
that patient data set and look at
the anticipated outcome of treatment decisions you want to make.
Yes, so as a physician or as
a nurse practitioner or
other mid-level care provider who are a lot of the clinicians who we work with,
I'm able to visualize the most likely glucose profile
with this patient based on the data that this patient's spend monitoring at home.
So RIMIDI is connected in to their Bluetooth enabled or cellular enabled device.
We're connected to technologies like health kit and other data aggregators.
And then, we do the modeling to show here on the screen,
what the most likely glucose values are at each point during the day.
And those are represented by these colored dots.
And now as I interact with the medications that the patient is
taking and for instance increase the amount of insulin that they're taking.
You'll see that the whole graph shifts in response to that intervention.
And so I can visualize the impact of that,
not only on their blood glucose but on
their hemoglobin A1C which is a long term measure of glucose control.
And that's quite important to the patient because we're helping
that patient also connect the dots between,
what I'm telling them today as their clinician
and what in my mind the anticipated outcome is.
And if we can help patients understand that
really understand what the goal of their therapy is.
We can also impact things
like adherence and engagement.
Sure, I think the friction
between a small company like ours that's innovative and a big
company like Cerner is always going to be speed.
So we can do things and
in you know on a dime and they can't and that's just their reality.
We were one of the first companies to come into the marketplace and so they were a lot of
processes still being put in place in terms of the agreements and the legal side of it,
that you know held it up longer than we wish it had.
But we understand that they need to standardize.
That's the goal of these marketplaces.
There's really a standard process for companies like RIMIDI.
What's been exciting has been to help them drive what some of that process
looks like and the fire resources they had available when we started.
I think greatly expanded and we've been able to have input on
that and help them understand how to
improve on the workflow that they supported
initially to make that better and better for their end users.
You know I think the biggest challenge right now is
it's always been market timing for us of you know.
First we need the platform companies to get on board and then we need enough of
their clients to be ready and actually be interested in deploying fire.
And that's finally happening this year,
I think 2017 will be the year where fire will become a reality
in the marketplace not just for early adopters but for the general market.
Part of that is you know driven by meaningful use
three requirements and the deadline coming up in January,
where a lot of the companies are leveraging fire to fulfill some of those requirements.
We're now leveraging what we've done with Cerner and with Athena
and we're building that out across other fire platforms
with the great hope that there will be minimal customization that needs to happen as long
as everybody is complying with the spec.
It's early to know that.
It's early to know at the individual customer sites.
How consistent fire resources will be as far as availability.
And will that differ from health system
to health system in terms of what they're allowing.
And then authentication is always the pain points.
I should have said that earlier that the fire integration and
exchanging of discrete data points is pretty simple.
The requirements around authentication not just
with the EMR company but with the individual clients is
definitely the heavier lift.
So, the response has been really terrific of having our capabilities
embedded in the EMR and I often say to
people I'd like for physicians to not even know we exist.
I'd like for them to think wow look what a fantastic feature Cerner has added.
And, so we're responding to that great feedback and saying okay,
how can we do this with other disease states?
We're rolling out a congestive heart failure capability
shortly and will continue to expand that across other chronic disease states.